quel bilan très sérieusement genre un
petit bonjour
quelle famille et pour mon mari parce
que je trouve
respire plus rapidement que d'habitude
la bonne c'est ainsi je ferai ce que ces
braves habitués à payer nos salaires
j'ai un immense émoi on a gardé un
document très fortement info monique
suède
il
ce que vous pouvez faire c'est le laissa
en body vous pouvez aussi modifier le
body et vous lui mettez ça peut l'aider
à réguler sa température
[Musique]
et
les premiers conseils c'est comment
rafraîchir sa pièce ou comment garder sa
pièce au frais c'est aussi à voir
comment se réhydrater parce que ça ne
passe pas que par l'eau ça fasse aussi
parce qu'on mange on donne des
informations et on peut vous rediriger
tous les sens il ya vraiment nécessité
si vraiment on arriva au bout de nos
compétences
[Musique]
le conseil que je leur donne fait
toujours un de faire preuve de beaucoup
d'empathie effectivement ce ce type de
profil derrière le mot j'ai chaud je ne
me sens pas bien il ya souvent
une détresse sociale une solitude on
constate avec les années que oui on a
mis en place les dispositifs pour
prendre en charge par rapport aux fortes
chaleurs mais le soutien moral est
encore malheureusement encore pour
certains et donc on a des personnes qui
sont isolés qui ont besoin de parler et
parfois c'est une idée coûte tout
simplement
[Musique]
ban